well I think there is a mental health
crisis I generally do I think in the
early 2010s there was this spike in
anxiety depression other things like
eating disorders
um and I think at the time a lot of
people thought that's just nothing new
that's just kind of adolescence and
coming of age like you
everyone feels a bit anxious has body
image issues at that time
um but if you look into it the self-harm
and suicide rate was also going up at
the same time
uh massively so like in America between
2012 and 2019 the suicide rate for white
middle-aged men increased by three
percent but for girls aged 10 to 14
increased by 138 wow so it's not it's
beyond the normal experiences of
adolescence whatever's happening
um but I think what's happening now is
you know young people are having all of
those age-old feelings of anxiety and
Body Image issues the normal stuff
but it's colliding with other things in
Modern Life like social media
um consumers and all of these things
that are kind of ramping up and I think
it's taking those normal feelings and
just exacerbating them to the absolute
extremes
138 yeah yeah that is absolutely
terrifying and it's awful yeah and and
you how much of this can be blamed on
social media do you think how much of it
can be blamed on the consumerism how
much can be blamed on other factors as
well well social media is a bit hard
because there's not actually like
definitive evidence that it's social
media
so some studies show barely any effect
of social media other studies show that
it's a huge impact
but one thing Jonathan height says which
I think is important is that when
they're looking at
um studies on social media they often
say screen time
which kind of lumps in texting and
scrolling through Instagram which has
different mental health impacts like
texting is not that bad for your mental
health so I think that's why it comes
out as barely anything depends who
you're texting yeah
so yeah so there's that so I think that
um
it's difficult to definitively say but I
think if you look at the Timeline so
mental health started to decline in the
early 2010s especially for girls
the iPhone came out in 2007. Instagram
came out in 2010 you had editing apps
like facetune came out in 2013 Snapchat
was doing its AR filters in 2016. so all
around that time
these things were happening and girls
mental health especially was declining
so you can say it's things like the
climate crisis or the economy that's
affecting mental health but why would it
be girls and why would it be such a
sudden decline at that time and for you
used something I'm sounding so old you
the the face moderating app yeah face
tune face so explain to people yeah like
me who are very old what is this app
what does it do what is the purpose of
it and what are the effects on young
girls so face tune isn't editing out
selfie retouching they call it
um and you can basically do anything on
it you can tan your skin you can whiten
your teeth you can restructure your face
they've just introduced a new feature
where you can you kind of film yourself
doing something like walking around a
room you can freeze the frame edit your
waist so it's tiny and then that when
you play the video that will stay for
the whole video and it looks like that's
just your body so the technology is just
seamless now you can't tell that it's
been edited
uh it's been downloaded like 60 million
times I think and I think it's something
like 75 of girls posting or users
posting on Instagram or using face tune
um and the funny thing about facetune is
that
you know it used to be a bit of a secret
among teenagers like they would use it
and they wouldn't want other people to
know that they're using it whereas now
it's kind of been rebranded in this
whole feminism self-love thing so face
Tunes marketing is very much about uh
self-expression and girls self-love so
for example on International women's day
they posted something like selfie selfie
editing is a powerful Act of
self-expression and it was to celebrate
feminism so the act of retouching your
selfies has become feminists so
pretending to look
in a way that you don't actually look is
now empowering yes yeah it's completely
changed well that's what all the
celebrities say I mean Khloe Kardashian
she literally facetuned her own newborn
baby when it was born and she calls it
life-changing you've got uh there's
YouTubers online who there's this guy
James Charles he's got 23 million
followers and he does this series where
he gets like pre-teen teen goes to send
in selfies and he will edit them so
he'll give them like a nose job
Contour them put makeup on them
and all the while he's saying oh this is
nothing there's nothing wrong with
fixing insecurities you know this is
self-expression and all of the comments
are like this is so educational this is
empowering uh so it's really interesting
to me that it's been completely
rebranded it's really interesting
because before the only people who could
do that were the Vogues of the world
exactly and they would take a celebrity
and they would slim them down and trim
their waist and whatever else and put
them present an unrealistic
representation of what that person
looked like yeah but now it's
democratized it everyone can do it yeah
I think there was in the early 2000s
like a backlash to the the photo
retouching in magazines and you know we
had growing mental health awareness
since then and I think corporations had
to come up with an answer and their
answer is to continue profiting off of
female insecurities but now wrap it up
in feminist packaging
foreign